divide and write the answer as a mixed
number and we have three fifths divided
by one half now whenever you're dividing
any fractions you just have to remember
that dividing by a fraction is the same
thing as multiplying by its reciprocal
so this thing right here is the same
thing as 3/5 as 3/5 times
so this is our 3/5 right here and
instead of a division sign you want a
multiplication sign and instead of a 1/2
you want to take the reciprocal of 1/2
which would be 2 over 1 so times 2 over
1 so dividing by 1/2 is the exact same
thing as multiplying by 2 over 1 and we
just do this as a straightforward
multiplication problem now 3 times 2 is
6 so our numerator is 6 5 times 1 is 5
so 3/5 divided by 1/2 as an improper
fraction is 6 fifths now they want us to
write it as a mixed number so we divide
the 5 into 6 forgot how many times it
goes that'll be the whole number part of
the mixed number and then whatever is
left over will be the remaining
numerator the remaining numerator over 5
so what we'll do let's take 5 into 6 5
goes into 6 one time 1 times 5 is 5
subtract you have a remainder of 1 so 6
over 5 is equal to 1 is equal to one
whole or 5 fifths and 1 over 5 and 1 and
1/5 this one comes from whatever is left
over and now we're done 3/5 divided by
1/2 is 1 in 1/5 now the one thing that's
not obvious is why did this work why is
dividing by 1/2 the same thing as
multiplying essentially by 2 2 over 1 is
the same thing as 2 and to do that I'll
do a little side fairly simple example
but hopefully it gets the point across
if I were to take let me pick take 4
objects so they have 4 objects one two
three four so I have four objects and if
I were to divide it into
of two so I want to divide it into
groups of two so that is one group of
two and then that is another group of
two how many groups do I have well 4
divided by 2 I have 2 groups of 2 so
that is equal to 2 now what if I took
those same four objects 1 2 3 4 so I'm
taking those same four objects instead
of dividing them into groups of two I
want to divide them I want to divide
them into groups of 1/2 which means each
group will have half of an object in it
so let's say that would be one group
right there that is a second group that
is a third group I think you see each
group has half of a circle in it that is
the fourth
that's the fifth it's the sixth that's
the seventh and then that's the eighth
you have eight groups of 1/2 so this is
equal to 8 and notice now each of the
objects became two groups so you could
say how many groups do you have well you
have four objects and each of them each
of them became two groups each of them
I'm looking for a different color each
of them became two groups and so you
also have eight so dividing by 1/2 is
the same thing as multiplying by two and
you can think about it with other
numbers but hopefully that gives you a
little bit of an intuition